uh welcome back uh to this third panel
incarceration decarceration in education
um
which is sort of formed around the
notion that universities in particular
have become centers for prison education
and re-entry programs as well as
abolitionist activity
how can we Foster such programs in the
future and how might they relate to the
decarceration movement
and our uh four panelists here I'm going
to introduce them very briefly all at
once and then uh let them take over
first of all uh Bernard Harcourt who's a
multifaceted intellectual and activist
professor at Columbia Law founding
director of the initiative for just
Society at Columbia Center for
contemporary critical thought also
deactile detude ethical
social in Paris the author of a dozen
books brilliant editor of several works
by Michelle Foucault lawyer for death
row prisoners in Alabama and teacher at
Rikers Island
and he'll be followed by Anton Henshaw
who's director of the transformative
Justice initiative which he founded to
support the formerly incarcerated on
their release from prison
you can see him on videos at the Gate of
East Jersey State Prison the first
agreed and embrace the newly released
Anton is also studying for his master's
degree at the school of Criminal Justice
of Rutgers University
next Zelda Roland uh ylba and PhD who's
the founding director of the Yale prison
education initiative which she almost
single-handedly has made an enormous
success including the award of a large
enabling Grant from the Andrew Mellon
Foundation she coordinates the Yale
program with the Connecticut Department
of Corrections and with a committed
group of Yale faculty and students and
with the University of New Haven
and finally our respondent Ben Berger
teaches political science at swarthbar
where he's executive director of The
Lang Center for civic and social
responsibility and in this role is
um
he's focused the center's mission on
connecting the curriculum of the
community in particular he's made prison
education a vital locus of engaged
scholarship stressing the ways in which
students inside and outside can
co-create knowledge and change public
perceptions and public policy so I'll
say no more and turn things over to
Bernard Harcourt
thank you Peter and thank you all for
an amazing conversation so far
um I'd like to start
with a series of
epigraphs
giving voice to writings from the prison
first is from George Jackson Soledad
Brothers
1970.
I met Marx Lennon Trotsky Engels and Mao
when I entered prison and they redeemed
me
for the first four years I studied
nothing but economics and Military ideas
from His Brilliant book Blood In The
Water blood in my eyes 1971.
George Jackson again
I would be sitting in a special locked
isolation cell sometimes even with the
lock welded shut and there would be no
one to talk to just the sound of
screaming voices because there's no
human contact you depend on books
no contact with people
special lock welded on the door nobody
around I'm strictly by myself the only
friend I had was a book
sometimes I'd find myself talking out
loud to the author I'd sort of wake
myself up and I'd hear myself talking to
this other person I guess it was some
kind of wish fulfillment when I'm asleep
at night I still find myself talking to
those guys
the next slide yes the next slide is uh
the next
epigraph is from Albert woodfox
a brilliant author of solitary the book
solitary unbroken for four decades in
solitary confinement he spent four
decades in solitary confinement
um sadly he passed away a few months ago
of kovid
uh the years in prison had worn his
health down
he writes in solitary
I turned my cell into a university
a hall of debate a law school
reading was my salvation
I first gravitated to books and authors
that dealt with politics and raced
George Jackson
Malcolm X Marcus Garvey Steve Biko
Eldridge Cleaver Solon Ice Jay Rogers
from Superman to man we read anything we
could find on slavery communism
socialism Marxism anti-imperialism the
African Independence movements and
Independence movements from around the
world leaning against my wall in the
cell sitting on the floor on my bed or
at my table I read
foreign
the next epigraph
is from a letter
uh
it was a letter that was written to
Albert woodfox by a man on death row
and he sent it through his attorney
George Kendall an old friend
and he'd send a message to Mr woodfox in
this handwritten letter dated December 9
2021
I tried to edit out some passages that
were but here's here's where he writes
to Albert woodfox OG Shaka dingue Cinque
which was his uh name inside
I myself and some other
socio-politically conscious comrades
have been having teach in sessions with
your book solitary here on death row
it is deeply inspiring and motivational
we wanted you to know this an idea that
just came to mind and you'll be able to
see a video of my conducting a
demonstration on the 35th anniversary of
the assassination of George Jackson just
know that there are brothers down here
and who stand in that righteous
tradition and we are still fighting on
Guerrilla love and respect
cycles of regenerative action
regenerative cycle spontaneous chain
reactions
permanent revolutions
what's so remarkable about prison
writing
about prison reading about prison study
is the way in which the written word in
prison circulates
and recirculates and Sparks and inspires
and nourishes and sustains new
revolutionary Cycles
George Jackson encountered Marx and Mao
in prison and became as Dr Joy James
says a dragon philosopher and
revolutionary abolitionist transforming
himself and his prison comrades into the
military wing of a Vanguard party the
Black Panthers Albert woodfox reads
George Jackson right as well as others
Mao's a little red book and he he too is
turned revolutionary
co-founding the first official chapter
of the Black Panther Party Behind Bars
today a person confined in death row
reads Albert woodfox reading George
Jackson and is rejuvenated in his
struggle against the oppression of his
confinement and his sentence of death
teach in sessions in prison reading
groups in prisons the cycle revolves
rejuvenating and transmitting the
passion the commitment the struggle the
revolution generating new political
Praxis the
what happened in California in 2010s was
simply remarkable with the short
Corridor Collective which was formed on
the in the essay in the in the shoe in
the secured housing unit uh in isolation
basically in Pelican State Prison
um
it was a collection of men held in
solitary for being allegedly leaders of
different uh racial gangs
including Todd ashker Arturo Castellanos
Antonio Gillen sitawa Jama Paul red and
others and they formed a reading group
to discuss the works of Bobby Sands and
Cesar Chavez the Black Panthers Michelle
Foucault and others
and as Professor Allegra McLeod recounts
she writes although the men could not
meet face to face or even see one
another from their solitary cells they
were able to organize and read the same
text past notes talk to one another
pushing the the pages torn from these
books through the vents and the drains
and the cracks in the walls
so that they could share the texts
and they were able to talk with each
other through the vents
and discuss and formulate an
understanding of their situation the way
in which the prison Administration was
using their racial identities to control
them a long journey that ultimately LED
them
to organize the country's largest ever
prison hunger strike in 2013 involving
more than 30 000 women and men
throughout California
California prisons who refused to eat
um
and ultimately leading to litigation and
other
organizing that ended indeterminate
solitary confinement based on gang
affiliations
reading Bobby Sands
inspiring them to action
uh
also what happened we were talking
earlier today about Jean jeanet
right who helps form the group
the group on of on Prison information in
1970 reflecting particularly on George
Jackson on all facets of the prison and
the repression at the time in France but
also in the United States and ultimately
fueling this text called the
assassination of George Jackson of which
Janae wrote the preface but a text that
would be published in France
less than three months after George
Jackson's uh homicide right as George
Jackson is killed on August I think it's
21 1971 and by and this book is
published by galimar which preface uh in
uh in November like November 10th of 71.
and it's remarkable the way in which all
of these Works inspired others and
philosophers to rethink and rethink the
prison and rethink society and had such
extraordinary uh cyclical
effects on philosophers like Michelle
Foucault Who as a result of this work
and his engagement in prison abolition
in France at the time
comes up with a completely different
model of our society based on Civil War
right and he would write in these
important lectures he delivered the
Matrix of all struggles of power of all
strategies of power and consequently
also the Matrix of all the struggles
regarding and against Power
is the Matrix of Civil War
so
one of the questions we pose ourselves
of course is how we engage in education
in the prison
um
and uh
what's clear to me of course is as
critical academics in in our
relationship to present education which
is one of the most important aspects of
Our Lives
um what's remarkable is that these
prison writings and experiences really
convinced me that the most genuine and
authentic Academy is the one that's
created by the women and men behind bars
in solitary on the short Corridor at
Angola or Parchman or Rikers right in
their reading groups and teach-ins
and their Critical examination
people behind bars form the true Academy
and you can hear this you can hear this
in in solitary you can you can see it
it's tangible you can feel it
when a friend man friend
uh
man Daryl Robertson is released from
Rikers Island
walking out of the New York County
criminal courthouse at 100 Center Street
in downtown Manhattan carrying as his
only property is only possessions
to 75 pound bags of books
more than a hundred books on his back
this is the only thing that had gotten
through his time at Rikers
it becomes clear that these spaces built
to confine to punish to do violence to
men and women
these spaces have turned into are turned
into by the people who are prison there
the true and genuine Academy where
critical thought and debate is really
most alive
sometimes I feel like our Ivory Towers
pale in comparison there isn't the same
Drive
almost there isn't the same hunger there
isn't the same need to read to critique
to engage in Praxis
um
and uh so moving forward and as we think
about kind of uh education and Justice
in education I think it's not always the
question of what we academics contribute
to the critique and practice of men and
women behind bars but instead how can we
in higher education transform ourselves
to better model the relationship between
critique and Praxis in the true Academy
that the people in prison create
one final thought
these prison writings they're
they emerge out of the depths
de profundis
as Oscar Wilde called it
George Jackson himself wrote from those
depths
capture he said imprisonment is the
closest to being dead that one is likely
to experience in this life
Oscar Wilde also wrote from those depths
and during his time at the reading
prison
he was so deeply affected by the
execution of a fellow prisoner he wrote
The Ballad of reading goal
the reading jail
on his release after two years of
incarceration for the crime of
homosexuality he signed it c33
that was his Prison number and so it
appeared originally anonymously
I think I'll
finish with a verse from that beautiful
text
this too I know
and why is it worth each could know the
same
that every prison that men build is
built with bricks of Shame
and bound with bars lest Christ should
see how men their brothers maim
thank you
foreign
good afternoon everyone
um
I'm in a peculiar position because uh
I'm blessed to be here though
um
I am
a lifer
I served 100 of a 30-year life sentence
in New Jersey's prisons I was
incarcerated in 1988 and I was released
in 2018.
um as I listened all day it's amazing
how
what we call inside Liberation education
makes this day possible
so for one I'm humbled I am blessed and
I thank you all for creating a space
where I'm safe and I'm
able to heal
and that we can heal together
Liberation education
I grew up in an environment
if you can imagine
where I wasn't supposed to survive I was
5'4 118 pounds never incarcerated before
and I was sentenced to 30 Years to Life
and I didn't go to a youth facility I
went straight to an adult male facility
and I was sent there to die or to be
fodder
for the other bigger stronger people
but I remember meeting two two men
at the orientation
and they asked me a question
what are you going to do play basketball
and be in the yard or go to school and
get an education
prior to my incarceration education has
always been my safe space
my mother abandoned me and my brother
and sisters
twice my father raised us he was an
authoritarian
um
and it led to a lot of what I used to
make decisions that led me to
incarceration
but when those two men asked me what was
I going to do I immediately remembered
my Elementary School principal Miss
Fenderson and I said School
I went to school
um and I got my GED within six months
after in prison and then I enrolled in a
college program at Mercer County
Community College in New Jersey to get
an associate's degree
I remember
um
the first semester I got two A's I
really didn't think I was College
material but I was and I went to sign up
for the next semester and the Pell
Grants were gone
and immediately I'm like what are you
doing I finally found something I like I
enjoy um I'm safe and I'm in a Maximum
Security Prison but I quickly learned
that the most violent people don't like
to be around books
right if you're in the library if you're
in um
the law library they don't go around
books or classrooms too tough they hang
around on the cell blocks and and they
want to run the block they want to run
the phone they want to run the mess hall
they want to control the haircuts and
all the things that that are don't
really mean anything all I cared about
was is that clock going to keep moving
so I can get out of here
um I was blessed to be around my prison
father Mr Jerome Perkins
and I begin to quickly learn from him
um the pearls of structural violence
right and how systems became
structurally violent whether you
participated in them or not
so we began to chart a course to get
education back in prison it took us 28
years
to get it back
and I remember
[Music]
getting
higher education back into New Jersey
state prisons by writing a white paper
to the legislators that went in a slew
of bills 4202.
in New Jersey and they took this section
to make education mandatory in all New
Jersey's prisons as it was written
and I remember she's um she's no she's
assembly
she was assembly woman then she is now
um
in the House of Representatives then
assemblywoman Bonnie Watson Coleman and
a few other Grace Spencer and kohino and
a few others came in and we did our
presentation
and education became mandatory inside
New Jersey's prisons did I ever think
that that was possible that they would
listen to us and then you begin to see
that it wasn't that
we inside the cultural space didn't have
voices it was that our voices were
silent
and it took people coming from the
outside to the inside to magnify those
voices
and so the Senators and the legislators
started coming in and they began to take
the lead from the people and our
families that were directly involved
we get to the point where I meet this
wonderful man Mr Peter Brooks
um I'm working at the time I was working
on my ba but at the same time I was
going through the parole process which
was the most depressing and hard thing
that I ever had to do and Mr Brooks
brought in a detective class among
detective and interrogations and
techniques and I remember reading all of
these different these different tropes
that he brought in
and I remember my first interview with
the New Jersey state parole board
and two days prior to that interview
Professor Brooks he don't like me
calling him that down but at the time
Professor Brooks brought in this video
on the read technique of interrogation
and when I walked into the room of the
two-man panel they immediately began
using the read technique of
interrogation
in my parole hearing
and two days prior we have to write a a
reflection paper and an analysis on this
stuff I'm sitting there like are they
serious
but
that's what we call Liberation education
right
um if you're not religious oriented but
I'm very spiritual but um I say there
there was some divine intervention there
I don't know I don't know what to call
it or what it was but it came in a
moment when I needed the most to be able
to understand what was about to happen
and how the structural violence of a
system was going to be perpetuated
against me if I wasn't prepared
educationally
so that system was able to push me
through to the to the final level of the
full board
and the way the full board went was
totally different than the two-man panel
now there's we know there's sharks in
the room so they're waiting to jump out
it's 12 people and two of the 12 are
going to attack you for absolutely no
reason and try to provoke an emotional
response to justify keeping you in
prison
now mind you I said I'm a lifer
that means I'm on parole for the rest of
my life I'm still a slave of the state
of New Jersey I have a travel pass to
get here
and
Professor Ben Berger had to be my escort
in order for my plantation owners in New
Jersey to give me permission to be in
Connecticut
So for anybody that thinks slavery is
over it is not
right this is why we have this national
campaign amend the 13th
to remove the exception Clause from our
national Constitution and state
constitution all throughout the country
so as we began to go through this
process in the New Jersey state parole
board they began to ask me you know in
the read technique they make you feel
comfortable let's talk about
um your Early Childhood life your best
memories and things like that then all
of a sudden Wham let's talk about the
day of your crime
no Segway no nothing we're just going to
get in what was you thinking
what were you feeling
now let's remember the entire 30-year
process you are surviving you are not
thinking about the very thing that led
you to that moment
and now in this interview because it's
not a hearing it's an interview to see
if you are qualified to serve the
discretionary portion of your sentence
in the community
it is a privilege this is not a right
so we're going to see if our cultural
slave
can come back out amongst us
under a convict leasing type system that
we still have social control over this
person
sounds like a lot of philosophy don't it
for cold
Hobbs lock right
but in order to associate that
we have to have
the academies with the academies that
are inside building Liberation education
models
to end the structural violence of
systems
so I remember
I got to one of the Sharks and he was a
psych ninety percent of the New Jersey
state parole board are
um former law enforcement
so you have to know what what you what
audience you're speaking to
and
he said to me you're a liar
everything you said is the farce it
doesn't make sense you're in here
deceiving us and he just went on with a
Litany of insults and I sat there
and he asked a question
later on he said well you don't have
anything to say
and I simply said I'm here to answer
questions you made a statement
he said so like you guys just did he
said
and the people in the room all did the
same thing his own colleagues was like
he's right
but that becomes critically aware
of a
Liberation education to not get dragged
into a conversation that's built mainly
built on accusations and not questions
I'm here to answer questions nothing
else
so he said well what do you think about
what I said about you
now again be careful what you sent
across the net you might not like what
comes back
and so I answered him I said um I know
that if I lie if I'm deceptive if I'm
not forthcoming in any way
that keeps me in prison for the rest of
my life and I will not waste your time
nor mine
and if you feel as though I'm lying and
then I'm being deceptive I'm sorry you
feel that way
because I wasn't speaking to one person
I was speaking to 12 and the majority
who voted would either vote to keep me
in prison or to release me
but I remember
the Sherlock Holmes and the detective
novels
that Peter Brooks brought inside
and how
the questions were being answered asked
and answered to get to a particular
result
right so it's about that you know that
that dance to not say what I think they
want to hear but to exercise my own
agency and my own Liberation and take it
in my hands and whatever happens I can't
control the outcome it's not my decision
but I can control my process
that's it
and it's the same way with education in
school and things like that I can just
put forth the best ideas that I can in a
piece on a paper or things like that but
what I find what was the hardest thing
for me was coming home I was punished
inside for writing
I did seven years on and off during my
30 years and isolated confinement
because of my political writings
I have yet to write anything of my own
thought when I came home
because I'm on parole and if they came
in my house they could pull it and they
could use that as justification of
putting me back
so I'm not free though I'm physically
free I was sharing with uh Ben
um the last I have a new parole officer
I had it six in four years and I'm on
level four and what that means is I see
my parole officer once I see them four
times a year quarterly
but I have a new parole officer and his
thing is oh that's the minimum standard
I can see you as many times as I want
and this and that I said well I have a
standard if you can just do whatever you
want you have broad discretion
so we got into this back and forth thing
so he came and did a home visit to my
apartment
and when he walked in he came in
triggering I'm very conscious about my
triggers and when I'm triggered I will
let people know around me that I'm
triggered and I'm not being aggressive
or anything but I and I said that to him
and so we get up in my apartment and
this guy says
well
um I'll be back next month I said no you
won't
and he says well you are on parole I
said yes I am and I said I've earned
level four to not have to see you
every month
and then he said
um well I feel like you're being
aggressive
and
um he said um
I um I I I'm concerned for my safety and
he stepped back
and put his hand on his service weapon
and when he did it I was like oh snap
so I walked into my kitchen and he
walked towards me
and I said to him I said I thought you
said that you were afraid for your
safety and that I was being aggressive
I'm trying to give you space so you
don't feel that way he says I'm gonna
need you to sit down I'm in my house
so I said uh I'm not going to do that I
said are you done with your search
are you done with whatever you came here
to do
now we're talking Liberation education
let's let's like really get think about
this
I am telling a person in authority
now to get out of my house
he takes his
um flashlight and begin to search my
house and my living room and says do you
have me on YouTube
so I'm like you're really triggering so
I opened the living room I'm open the
door because it's right by my living
room and I say you have to leave
but then later on I called Professor Ben
and was like yo I don't know what this
guy's going to do I don't know but
immediately with our education and how
we do things one thing is do process
rights
right I'm only asking for what I'm
entitled to by due process and law I'm
not asking for anything extra I'm not
asking for any particular
uh special treatment
the beautiful thing about everything
that happened
is was the controversy and the abuse of
discretion allowed me to navigate safely
using Liberation education that allowed
me to survive 30 years
and how to turn that into a transferable
skill
on the street
and coming out and saying I
if need be
how I survived 30 years through books
through those very things that you
talked about
um
book clubs we had over 1500 books in
East Jersey State Prison we have our own
library that we built
they banned the new Jim Crow really
right blood in my eye if you got caught
with that it is six months solitary
confinement
Contraband immediately you're going to
the hole
right
um
but
my grandmother
who is
um Native American she would introduce
me to Black Red Cloud and Red Cloud had
a saying that I used every day while I
served 30 years
every day is a good day to die
every day is a good day to die
and I think I never really got to thank
Mr Peter
for
providing that lesson in that season
to liberate me
from incarceration thank you
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
just to acknowledge that I'm on this
level
you're at that level that was amazing
thank you
um
I think that was really
important
can you hear me
um
all right I wanna of course thank Peter
for having me
um inviting me organizing this
incredible symposium
I want to really process and appreciate
uh both of the panelists here
and also
in advance thank you for being kind to
me
um
and I also I really quickly want to
acknowledge and thank all of the um
faculty here who've taught in our prison
education program
who serve on our faculty advisory
committees
Caleb Smith Elizabeth Hinton Randall
Horton uh and also fellows and alumni of
ypei here
um people who've worked with our program
a lot of familiar faces here so I'm
really glad that I'm gonna
um
spare you uh my um typical
fundraising presentation
um
also I see a few members of stop
solitary which is cool yeah
uh so I'm punching above my weight here
a little bit on this panel I'm what you
would call a practitioner or if you're
being a little less charitable an
administrator
uh I imagine I was asked to sit on this
panel because I have something to say
not just as someone who runs a prison
education program but especially also as
someone who figured out how to build one
at the most unlikely of places the
university Where We Gather today
um
and the short story is we found the
glitch in The Matrix
um
what I'd like to do with my brief time
is telling you just a little bit about
the program here at Yale and through our
partnership with University of New Haven
and what it is that we do
for context
um and then highlight some details in
vignettes from the overlap of the twin
institutions of the prison and the
university that touch on the larger
theme of the Symposium
incarceration and Imagination and also
this panel which has been titled
incarceration decarceration and
education
and because I work deeply with an
Institutional bureaucracies of the
prison and the university one of the
things I set out to do for myself and
agreeing to sit on this panel is use it
as an opportunity for my own reflection
about the acts of imagination that were
and are required in order for this
program to exist
so the program was in a way in its own
way created by incarcerated students
um the seed of origin is through
Wesleyan Center for prison education or
myself and other faculty and graduate
students at Yale had been volunteering
for years and years around the time that
I started volunteering at Cheshire
through wesleyan's prison education
program in 2014
it was a semester I was supposed to be
writing my dissertation so of course I
was looking for any excuse um for
distraction
um
I um I kept finding on campus that there
were a lot of different faculty here who
were really invested in this who were
excited
um who were excited about teaching in
prison who thought it was really
important
and that it really
made serious
[Music]
um
their vocation in a in a way that
teaching on campus
maybe haven't
um and so as I started going in more and
more and meeting more of these faculty
and graduate students who were deeply
invested in wesleyan's program or bards
program at The Bard prison initiative
the students at Wesleyan encouraged me
to start a program at Yale
they knew that well first they thought
there's a lot of prisons in this state
and a lot of them don't have programs
like ours and if you could start a
program at Yale it would really benefit
a lot of people
this was at Cheshire and they said some
of us had to transfer from other prisons
just for the shot at applying to this
program
but they also in that program knew that
a program at Yale would have more than
just a direct impact it would have a
national impact it would Inspire other
institutions of Higher Learning
competitive institutions who as we all
know only
um do things to outdo each other that it
would create this ripple effect and that
it could be hugely important if we could
start a program at Yale other programs
could look to us and say
Yale did it we can too
um and that was inspiring to me to think
about the possibilities if we could get
that far
so a few of us started Gathering
Together The Faculty oh I want to call
out Ron Jenkins who's been teaching in
prison for a long time uh Ron was there
at our first
um meeting of Yale faculty who'd been
teaching in prison and who really wanted
to brainstorm this was 2014 or 2015. how
would we start a program here how would
we do it
um there had never before been
a student in prison who could say they
were part of a real Yale program and
there had never been a program that
offered real Yale credits
um and we also counted Among Us formerly
incarcerated students and graduate
students on our campus who'd been alumni
of college and prison programs who were
in graduate school
um or who were undergraduates even
um we convened a small meeting
to do this imaginative work together
what would this program look like and
how would we pull it off
um as an aside in working to build this
program I spent
some time considering the history of
admissions at ivy league universities of
course the story of inclusive changes in
admissions here and elsewhere is not
ever the story of spontaneous of a
spontaneous and benevolent increase in
access to the campus but a story of
resistance by small and subordinate
groups
and that is indeed the story of how our
program was started it was one of a
fierce Coalition of Faculty staff
students administrators many many
administrators and many offices the
registrar's offices who for whatever
reason believed in it
formerly incarcerated students as well
who came to campus attended meetings
with Deans at Yale and also with
commissioners of Correction
and who pushed until the program finally
seemed inevitable
[Music]
um
which it still seems
but one lesson I I learned along the way
that I thought this might be a good form
to share
um is that it appeared to me in this
time that the university and this is a
cynical observation
um that maybe we can think about
together but the university is built
specifically
to preempt any one student or individual
from creating real impact in under four
years
four years is the amount of time it
takes to create any sort of lasting
change
um I don't know how to
subvert that sort of rule of thumb that
I've come to understand but in those
four years that we pushed for this
program an incredible shift happened on
this campus and many of the Deans or
registrars that we met with at the
beginning who truly looked at me and
said I don't physically understand what
you're talking about do you mean inmates
are coming to campus and I'd say no you
know faculty are going to drive
themselves to prison you know and then
they're going to be in a classroom and
in that classroom they'll you know to
really paint the picture and
um you know and we came out on the other
side and some of those Deans are some of
you know the best evangelists of this
program today
um so today we have a program that
operates year-round through a
partnership with the University of New
Haven
uh we offer both Yale and UNH classes
for credit with faculty and sometimes
graduate students from both institutions
teaching students are matriculated in an
AAA in General Studies And a ba in
interdisciplinary studies if students
are released before they complete their
degree they can seamlessly transition to
on-campus enrollment at UNH which is
very unique in this field
um together we've facilitated
431 unique enrollments and credit
bearing courses with 121 faculty staff
and graduate students from both campuses
teaching guest lecturing or otherwise
offering access to their on-campus
research and teaching
and
over 200 undergraduate students have
worked with us as volunteers or tutors
in various capacities
um this semester we'll graduate our
first students from the degree program
and today
uh students at Danbury federal prison
um or women rather at the Danbury
federal prison uh just you know near
nearby from here
um are receiving admissions letters to
our first cohort for a new program at
that facility
we've also just been approved to
facilitate Federal Pell Grants in prison
as a part of this national movement that
Anton mentioned to restore Pell Grant
access for students inside
um and there is a lot to be proud of
and yet also a lot that is wrong with
how things have evolved
um there are things that you know we
didn't succeed at in building this
program
um and there are things that I believe
we still will succeed at and a lot of
this work requires a lot of imaginative
thinking and I'll get to that in just a
second
um but I do quickly and then I'm gonna
end
um
I I just have
several discrete acts of imagination
from our prison education program that
were required to build and to sustain it
right in addition to
what I just mentioned continuing to
imagine the ideal version of this
program but the first was over those
years of building it
building a program for an imaginary
group of students right working with
current students in another program
knowing students from other programs
but nevertheless fighting
um through these institutions a
Department of Corrections and an
institution of higher education to
create a credit bearing or degree
granting program for a group of students
that you don't personally know right and
so you know a group of students who
simply have not ex you know do have not
applied to the program right and which
is why one of the um best days in our
lives as um
you know prison education administrators
is admitting a new cohort of students to
a prison
um admitting a news to cohort of
students to a prison education program
sitting down with them and really saying
this is for you you know this is being
in that room and especially with our
first cohorts at any prison is really
um you know the perfect culmination of
imaginative thinking
not the perfect combination a good a
fine culmination
um
another Act of imagination reading a
student handbook to students in prison
it's
um one of the core principles of this
program is really we're extending access
to the same college classes the same
programming
that we offer to students here and we
hold to the same rules and regulations
we hold to the same standards and we sit
there on the first day and read
every little rule that students are
trusted to read on their own uh here on
campus
and reading that student handbook
is a little bit
odd because some of these rules simply
don't apply
but
the work that it does is in helping the
students to understand themselves as
students
as peers to students on our campus that
they are bound to those same
ways
of being a student
um a third Act of imagination is the way
we constantly
um
use and reimagine the Yale mission
statement
we use as our mission statement for ypei
the mission statement of Yale College to
seek exceptionally promising students of
all backgrounds from across the nation
and around the world and to educate them
through mental discipline and social
experience to develop their intellectual
moral Civic and creative capacities to
the fullest the aim of this education is
the cultivation of citizens with a rich
awareness of our heritage to lead and
serve in every sphere of human activity
so we take this mission statement
and we read it every day through an
abolitionist lens
and the way we do that is we imagine
that if we can't imagine together a
post-carceral future then the leaders of
that future may very well be
incarcerated today are incarcerated
today and in that scenario the charge of
the university is to invest now in those
students as Future Leaders and citizens
so you don't have to change anything
about the mission statement to read it
through that lens but it is a
it is a way that we have to work to
imagine it serving a different purpose
um my fourth uh Act of imagination
um
is a little anecdote uh and then I'll
cut myself off because I have many acts
of imagination
um
creating
um Yale within the prison is an
interesting practice for us if you can
imagine our faculty or volunteers and
our staff
are a certain subset of Yale citizens
and
[Music]
um
we you know we bring in a lot of
you know a lot of the faculty that you
see here and there's a lot of
undergraduates who volunteer who are
students of color or who are radical
activists who believe you know there's
there's a lot of um a lot of uh
community in the people who enter the
prison
um
and I remember one day a couple years
ago we had a sort of as Peter mentioned
I went to undergrad and grad school here
um and we had a student who was
volunteering who maybe more fit your
traditionally he's like a very tall
lacrosse player very white and blonde
and he came into the prison and you know
our students are mostly black and brown
from you know neighborhoods and
Connecticut cities and they
um
and uh and they looked at this guy and
they said he doesn't look like a Yale
student to me
and I was like oh yeah we've created
like an ER M College
at McDougall Walker Correctional
institution and it was a really strange
feeling because especially a couple
years ago when this happened we were
really there wasn't very much interest
in teaching or learning in the program
we had you know uh some interest but
that semester we had Rod Ferguson and
you know Lisa Lowe and Dan house saying
and lemir core co-teaching ER M because
that was all we could do
um and so uh you know having that kind
of reality check was really it it was a
it was a weird
it was a weird moment but it also helped
me think about how we've created this
version of Yale we've imagined this
version of Yale within the prison
um
okay and I'm gonna end with just a
little reflection and something maybe
slightly uncomfortable
um I'm super grateful to be sitting here
next to Anton there's something a little
bit strange about being at this simple I
don't I don't have an answer to this
this is just my notes a little bit
strange about being at a symposium with
Scholars and writers and everyone's got
a friend in prison you know or a person
they write letters to or about or who
they teach or refer to it's a little bit
itchy
it's a little bit itchy
um but it also does this really
important work we were talking earlier
about making the invisible visible
bringing to the Forefront of discussion
people who are hidden from view people
actively currently in prison
um
and am I out of time
just us you know so yeah okay I just had
like a little
um
paragraph but
um
a little bit off topic but my background
is in film studies and one thing I've
written about is background actors in
classical Hollywood so in the 20s and
30s there were these cycles of prison
films that fetishized using actual
prison locations often with the
permission of like a very enthusiastic
Hollywood hungry Warden and then beyond
that they would use actual prisoners in
the backgrounds of the films and in most
of these scenarios it was required by
the prison and by the motion picture
industry that the background actors
could not be portrayed in any degree of
specificity unless they require Fair
compensation
so sometimes in the backgrounds
of films that would take place in prison
you'd see people who were incarcerated
but they were masked in order to
suppress their identity their portrait
you see
and I wasn't even going to talk about
this but after the rest of the I was
sort of thinking about it and I'm
thinking about this history and the work
that that people are doing
in accompanying portraits of individuals
on the inside making this sort of
invisible visible
um
and uh
yeah that's it all in there
[Applause]
I want to leave sometime if I can too
for uh some questions from the audience
I'm sure after these terrific
presentations there will be
um some so
um I'm Ben Berger Swarthmore College
um like Tracy Mears before me I I'm
going to try to respond not just to the
terrific presentations we've had here
but also to some of the things that have
been said earlier in the day and even
from at the dinner last night for for
presenters to try to give maybe a little
bit of a sense of all the things that Ty
have tied us together I'm really
grateful as others are as well to uh to
Peter for bringing us together and
there's this kind of simpatico on this
particular panel I I met Peter when I
was at Princeton I was the Rockefeller
visiting Professor for distinguished
teaching there and he had been the same
thing a few years before we connected
through that I was teaching a class an
inside out class that would say I
brought Princeton students into Easter's
East State Prison
um and they took a class alongside the
incarcerated students
um that was something that Peter is
interested in doing as well we talked a
lot about that he had taught at egsp he
had taught tone who had come home
already and told him became my guide to
figure out I I was experienced in prison
teaching but every institution is
different and you've got to figure out
what to do where and the the kind of
advice I got from Tung was just
invaluable and it wasn't just at the
beginning of the semester it was
throughout the semester
Bernard and I have talked about know a
lot of people in common because we've
gone to some of the same schools he's
just done a lot more than I have but I
don't hold that against him and his book
critique and practice is fabulous and
you should get it because it's informed
my thinking about some what we're
talking about today it's a recent book
and it's not just if you want to
understand critical theory but also if
you really want to understand actually
what a critical theorist and one who's
also an activist might do in pushing
back against himself always questioning
am I doing enough am I doing the right
thing which is something that all of us
ought to be doing really
the overarching theme that I want to
talk bring together is the one of
imagination and Bernard reminds us with
the example of reading groups in the
carceral spaces and tone reinforces with
his really moving examples of them
um
that things don't happen we don't build
things unless we can imagine them
all right unless unless they already
happen to us in our experience or if we
can imagine them and books are one way
of doing that and not just books but
then talking about books with other
people as well so that's the basic power
of imagination to help us to figure out
what we might be able to build that just
can't be underestimated I want to
recount a few things from other panels
to set the stage for what we're talking
about here Joy James this morning
wondered about the protective mechanism
that authors of fiction might be able to
offer the incarcerated if some
incarcerated people have difficulty
being seen by the public now Caleb
pointed out that there are some truths
that people in power don't want
incarcerated right to tell or other
writers to tell about the incarcerated
there's a double bind you want to say
the right thing but not say too much and
not get in trouble with the powers that
be
and Rachel Kushner shared with us the
story of The Poetry editor
that said for a prisoner's bio they
would they could include only the
person's name age where they were
incarcerated and the crime for which
they were convicted that was the bio
nothing else about the person there was
a kind of Vanishing a kind of Erasure a
strict control over the resources that
readers might be able to access when
they create the film in their mind of
thinking about life for that
incarcerated person and I think most of
us agree that's not an accident
it's not an accident there is strict
control telling the story you told about
the the parole officer even outside the
prison and the control that that's
exercise it's not an accident
one of the things that struck me most
forcefully when I started doing prison
teaching was this intentional Erasure of
bodies and personalities a Vanishing of
people not just from the broader public
but sometimes even from families as well
the inability to bring pictures out my
group at Princeton we took a class
picture we had somebody from one of the
photography groups come in and take a
picture of us
I smuggled that out I wasn't supposed to
have it get out of the prison it seems
ridiculous why shouldn't we have a PR a
picture of us there but we weren't all
right picture even images weren't
supposed to uh to go out and so it's one
of the reasons why I appreciate not only
prison education programs in general
like Zelda the one you've created here
and my my hat is off to you
but especially the Inside Out model that
was created at greaterford prison now
called The Phoenix and Temple University
so I practiced the Inside Out model
people all over the world do it as well
that is where like at Princeton that one
ear right you you have a class inside
the car show facility and there are
students from your home institution
they're the outside students together
the incarcerated students they're the
inside students and you're reading the
same books you're writing the same
papers having the same discussions they
are transformative but what they also do
is they allow outside students to go
home and realize and tell other people
too this is the kind of Erasure I saw
what's actually going on and it's not
what's being portrayed out here so it's
one way in which a little way in which
their imaginations and what they convey
to others can be expanded in terms of
possibly changing things as well
um Zelda this great work you've done
again here with Yale we're trying around
Swarthmore and in Pennsylvania more
broadly to create our own kind of prison
education system we're woefully but I
mean Villanova's got its own great
program but PA doesn't we're trying to
kind of copy what's in New Jersey I
learned so much about NJ step through
tone at where there is one Central
School that's Rutgers that grants the
Bas no matter who at what school Drew
Princeton wherever my teacher class
inside but but Rutgers is the ba
granting institution and then Raritan
Valley Community College is the AAA
granting institution we're trying to do
something like that with Penn State as
the main one so that when I teach a
course inside my students have credit
towards a Penn State um a Penn State
degree or a community college degree
um but here's the thing and I want to
raise this to Bernard is and also to
Zelda this is not really a critique it's
where I want to lift something up
um as kind of an expansion not a
critique and it came up last night at
dinner with Rich Rivera and tone we had
a fabulous conversation in about inside
life but also coming home and re-entry
and about parole boards as well
and Rich made the really interesting
point that I mean shouldn't come as a
surprise to us but sometimes you gotta
have things brought to the level of
Consciousness to really deal with them
that of course we don't want to just
hold everybody inside before they come
home or before they're considered a
success that they are like tone or rich
people you've met who have come home
often are just
amazing people they would have succeeded
anywhere in the world they're people who
had the drive to go through a college
degree to become paralegals to do all
kinds of stuff but there are many paths
to success and it doesn't have to come
necessarily just through books
a particular kind of book a particular
kind of discussion group that doesn't
invalidate I mean we're dedicated to
that we're we're intellectuals we're
academics Rich pointed out that if you
play basketball for 20 years you're
dedicated to that it takes more than we
can recognize because of the scariest
resource courts are a scarce resource
being able to stay dedicated focused
stay out of trouble the many different
things you've got to do to be able to do
that for 20 25 years that stuff that
will work on the outside too that's
stuff that needs to be recognized as
well so it may be one thing that some of
us here can try to lift up to the
broader public who can put pressure on
parole boards to say well it's not just
one way you don't have to be someone
who's got a perfect GPA or something to
be able to to come home again that's
that's an expansion not a critique I
think of what what uh what you guys are
working towards and zeld I wanted I was
asking zelders before this but I'd love
to talk afterwards too about the
possibility of of bridge programs for
folks who aren't ready right away to
come in and start a college program
inside but want to having tutors in
place having Yale tutors in place or
wherever the school is to help get them
to the level where now you're ready to
start all right and so we're not only uh
dealing with people who say I want to
read Mao right now I want to read marks
right now right so there's lots of paths
to that kind of success I'm um I'm drawn
to uh let me just say one thing about
imagination broadly it was the theme of
today so we uh so we we talked about
like visibility uh and uh Tracy gave a
great little sort of pushback about
visibility well maybe that's not enough
because some things are visible but they
don't necessarily lead to change we may
we may ignore them we may push back
against them so what I want to specify
with imagination is is that imagination
needs building blocks it needs food not
food for thought but food for
imagination so I think a little bit of
Thomas Hobbes you don't have to like
Hobbs overall political Theory or even
endorse his atomistic approach to the
world to to like this what I'm going to
put out there he says that he says
imagination it's particles it's
particulate so since uh the world meets
us here through our our experiences our
sense or our sense organs process that
and then afterwards the kind of Echoes
of that they become available to us
these faint imprints as imagination but
it's only things we've encountered
already you can't imagine something you
had no idea about you might encounter
through somebody else telling you about
it or through your experience we need
food we need particles to feed the
imagination and Zach said something
earlier about novelists possibly being
able to order and organize the particles
that the rest of the world sees that's
what I want to put out there there's
lots of information that could come out
to make things less invisible about
prisons but we need people who are going
to be able to organize the particles
into something then they can expand a
popular imagination about what's
actually happening and what could happen
as well so I heard a lot of sub themes
like that today I just want to kind of
lift that up I hear that in in um in
today's today's panelists as well to
build to rebuild to reform reboot to
revolutionize we have to be able to
imagine it now just because you can
imagine something doesn't mean that it's
possible you could imagine flying pigs
and maybe maybe genetic engineering well
I don't know what that's going to come
up but right now they're not possible so
it may not be sufficient but it's
necessary you got to be able to imagine
it and that's what we've got to expand
um
so let me see I'm gonna say only a
couple more things so I can get to some
other questions and comments on the um
the panelists ah right tone when we go
to to questions and and conversation I'd
love to invite you to expand on
something that we've talked about before
and you've also talked about with
Bernard luzelda with Peter on different
occasions about
a way of expanding imagination through
changing the rhetoric and not no longer
talking perhaps about just crime but
about public health the public health
model I'd love you to invite to invite
you to do that once I wrap up here I
think it's really deep and it shows the
importance of rhetoric to organize the
particles to be able to get people on
board because here's the other thing
I think we're not often the folks here
are probably pretty much on the same
page when it comes to a lot of issues
regarding the cultural States
it's a lot of issues regarding Injustice
and What needs to change but it's a big
country and not everybody agrees and
we've seen some horrifying ways examples
of polarization and yet you need other
people it's unless you just want to
think that a very small band are going
to change everything and we saw that
kind of on January 6 and it thankfully
didn't work out but unless you want to
go that path you need a lot of people to
be brought in and so you may need to put
things in other languages as well I
sometimes wonder if it wouldn't be
better to have something like a
situation comedy written by incarcerated
folks but at many different institutions
so that the stories they're talking
about couldn't be recognizable all
coming from one place but their stories
real stories within characters who are
humanized for lack of a better word to
the larger population
sitcoms and popular culture music also
hip-hop music those things get through
to a lot of people in the way that
languages often don't and can create the
atmosphere for social change so I don't
care if it's a sitcom or what the thing
is I just mean stories that go out there
that aren't just accusatory and that
actually say actually we a lot of us
share the same things here a lot of us
know people who are in or in prison a
lot of us have relatives whether we are
living in this part of the country that
part of the country we're all hurt by
this our communities are hurt when
people are taken out of the the
workforce our families are hurt when
parents are taken out of the parenting
environment and that's something that we
all share so I want to invite to think
about together different ways Beyond
also just the academic although I am an
academic of course
all right
last thing engage scholarship Peter
mentioned that I direct the center at
Swarthmore its focus is engaged
scholarship it used to be
community-based learning when I came in
we changed it to engage scholarship
because it's broader it lets a lot more
faculty in who are doing maybe things on
public policy maybe things that aren't
just about working in a particular local
community
Ernest Boyer coined that term
two what he meant by it was engaged
scholarship is turning orienting the
resources of the University towards our
most pressing public problems issues
ethical issues Civic issues ETC however
what Boyer missed was this it's more
than that now what we try to do now is
perspective taking you've got to be
problem solvers with folks who are
affected by stuff not for them that's
what this work is doing it's why all the
kind of educational stuff you're talking
about doing so so important it's what
tone and I have done together tone and
other people at egsp made me see I just
never thought about it before those who
are making policy for re-entry all right
have no experience with re-entry at all
of themselves all right being informed
by people who are inside who are about
to come out those who have recently come
out and their families who actually know
something about what's needed is just
the obvious way to go in fact it seems
idiotic to do any any other way and yet
we do it every other way but that so I
just want to call on even more doing
things with to be able to get better
better Solutions that's the kind of
thing I'm inspired by today a lot of
people doing with and doing with expands
our imagination tremendously so thanks
very much for everyone being here
yeah let's have questions from one
another to one another for a few minutes
and then we'll open it to the audience
[Music]
um
to answers Ben's question
while inside
um one of the biggest hurdles to get
over was Public Safety
um how do you bring in a chess program
and play Princeton University students
when it's a threat to Public Safety it's
threat to the people that are coming
into the institutions
um and it's a threat that if someone
takes a hostage to the safety of the
guards and how they run things so what
we did was
um through what we call Liberation
education we was introduced to a concept
called Public Health
right
this is a way of changing the health of
this institution
and this at the time I was incarcerated
in Trenton state prison now known as New
Jersey state prison I did 20 years there
and I did my last 10 at East Jersey
and what wind up happening was
when we won that first argument by
Framing it through a public health lens
this will reduce violence this will
reduce different things it'll teach
cognitive thinking critical engagement
it'll do a lot of things just with this
so our first
um our tournament was with
um Princeton we had 60 people but I
think Trenton is 1100 people
um 800 signed up
and then it became an instrument to
incentivize
and we wind up
um
we wind up being in
on ESPN while we were inside most people
don't look at chess as a sport but chess
is a sport
right
um so when I tell the youth that I work
with right now and
um Rutgers youth success program in
Camden
um I set up you know I was on ESPN Mr
Chong you captain
I'm like I'm like and I was in Sports
Illustrated yeah right
right you ain't got no game like that
but I got the article on my computer
here if you want to see it later on yeah
yeah so and a lot of people like when I
when I opened it up and it was like well
how was y'all able to do that in there
and I said through the public health
space
right in a harm reduction strategy
and it greatly reduced uh institutional
violence because people wanted to get
into the chess club in order to play
against Princeton like the elite like
they thought they were something and
they they would do all of that and what
wind up happening was
um when I got to East Jersey
um that's how we introduced the concept
to the administrators and the
commissioner of Corrections using a
public health argument I've never lost a
public health argument in in in in in in
Institution
right and coming home and bringing that
same
um cultural organizing to the community
it's like you know I remember I've never
been to Brooklyn in my life I've only
seen Brooklyn in the movies and on TV
and I went to Brooklyn and we were in um
this housing project and
I remember giving a presentation and
saying well we don't have to defund the
police
right I said all we have to do is
repurpose the money to Public Health and
address the public health and treatment
as opposed to punishment and you can
continue to do what you want over here
but we're going to address it through a
public health lens and a harm reduction
strategy and what wind up happening was
um one of the side effects of the talks
is when I got off the stage and I walked
down the police started surrounding me
and immediately I got triggered and I'm
thinking oh my God what did I say now
like I'm you know here we go and they
all came and when they surrounded me
they was like
I did not understand what you said about
we didn't have to defund the police can
you explain it I said if we
strictly focus on dealing with the
social issues through a public health
model
and a harm reduction strategy there's
money already sitting there in Surplus
that we're not using
there's billions and billions of dollars
there and it's not reaching the
communities that desperately need them
especially black and brown communities
so I remember it was um Sergeant Morgan
um he's probably the only second officer
that ever shook hands with
and he was like
can I have your phone number and can I
have your email address
so I'm looking at my guys who more
dollar than
um most of the people that I work with
have served in ordinance amount of time
the minimum is 28 years
the highest is 52 years
and we imagined while we were inside
we have our own school that we purchase
from the Board of Education in the city
of Camden
we have our own Studio we have our own
cameras green screen production we have
our own business district
but because we imagined it when it
didn't exist and came home and
manifested through a public health
agenda and a harm reduction strategy
information
uh we have a very patient audience I
think we should give him a voice now if
that's okay
questions yeah
there's a there's a mic somewhere yeah
it's on
hi my name is Charlie uh first of all I
would like to thank you guys for having
this event I found out about it on
Facebook
um
I served about two decades came home
recently and I'm still shaking off the
shackles of being institutionalized and
um
I would just like to invite anybody that
would like to pick my mind maybe through
my I have a mountain of uh experience
and knowledge on this topic
and um
I would just like to give back in any
way I can so
um if anybody would like to reach out
and pick my mind I'm here you can catch
me at charlierock LD prisonmentality
gmail.com
thank you guys
Rachel yes a question for any of the
five of you who would care to answer it
um
thanks those presentations were amazing
um just I sometimes sorry unless we're
gonna elect myself of sort of state of
mystery not of the state but as a
Californian
um we have a the scope and particularity
of our prison system is maybe somewhat
unique but um they you know it's very
unnatural I think that incarceration
involves a separation of the genders and
um women's prisons in California
uh I'm sorry to generalize but I'm going
to because I would really like to hear
what you all think about this
um like the culture of learning and
intellectual strength and enriching the
mind and having an interior life that is
inviolable by the staff and the guards
that is not really robust in California
women's prisons and I've had long
conversations with people inside prison
about this and people explain things to
me about why it's not robust and they
have real reasons like you don't
understand what it's like in here most
people come from profound trauma they're
trying to order their mind all the time
and deal with
um a kind of high drama environment
where there's eight people to a room etc
etc and no one has privacy
and so it is it has not been one of the
main Avenues to a kind of psychic or
mental Liberation for people and I was
wondering if you could just talk about
your experiences as teachers and as
students and
um whether this comes up in other places
is California unique in that way and if
not like
how to think about this
um uneven distribution of forms of
Liberation through intellectual work
through Reading
years
do you guys do both so like I said we
started our programming in the federal
women's prison today
this morning people were delivered um
their admissions letters uh so I can't
speak with much expertise about I mean I
am I'll tell you
women's prisons are different
you know uh
we've you know already in just the short
while that we've been you know we had
information sessions and ran interviews
there um but I do think I mean I'm not
sure what security level those prisons
are there is you know what you describe
sounds similar to the environment of
this prison where we're working which is
essentially
I mean it is literally a warehouse that
was purchased by the Bureau of Prisons
and converted into a satellite location
for the federal prison and so
the women who are there are in one large
gymnasium test type room
um and so the
boundaries between people are not that
you know peop there's a lot of um
you know I I think I mean I think I
suspect you might be right I but I I
really don't know in particular but I do
think that security level has a lot to
do with what is possible and able to
happen
um which is a little bit of an oxymoron
because we found in the high maximum
adult prison where we work which is you
know not
no prison is where anybody should be or
ideal but it's especially not ideal but
people at least have some alone time and
then they have communal time in the
prison where we are at the women's
prison where women are put in one room
they there isn't that
alone we really are going to have to
build it out right spaces especially
spaces are really important in this
context finding a space for people to
have a group that is able to meet not
just once a week but every single day
you know like to be in an environment
where you can imagine yourself as a
college student not just
Wednesday evenings but all the time
yeah
um you know I think it's fair to say
that um women have within this space of
the invisible
uh women in prison have been the
invisible within the invisible
throughout much of the history since the
1970s
um and but I think you know I think it's
going to be
context and history and person specific
in New York uh a lot of the work and the
teaching I've been doing at Rikers has
been at Rosie's which is the women's
facility uh
and um and there was a big emphasis on
on providing
courses from Colombia at Rosie's in
particular
um and the Columbia Justice and
education program in part was built by
uh Kathy Boudin and um Joe Wilkins uh
and
spent has has really dedicated a lot to
the Bedford facility so
um in part I think it's going to be
somewhat uh path dependent on who it is
that's doing the work and spearheading
the efforts and stuff you know
I um
um it's
you raise an interesting question
and which is the irony is we look to
California and the writing's from
California on the East Coast
and they're on the they're on the west
coast and what you just proposed was
sort of what reminds me of what just
happened
um in a lot well it's been happening for
quite a while and at the Mayhem in New
Jersey with the beatings and the rapes
and the things of women and where they
have this institution
all right so one of the things is is
what I what I what I was annexing
um in a lot of our
um our protests was the location of the
prison
right you treat it the same way you
treat domestic violence people
women and how they do the first thing
they did was isolate them
right they put them in a far out place
where nobody can get to them that's what
most DB violators do
right so the institution is not by any
public transportation you can't get
there by train bus
or anything
and they're remote
and that isolation and that stat that
isolation serves as a means of social
control inside the cultural space
and when you do it that way right
it's by Design so what they're
manifesting and what they're explaining
to you so it's like when I begin to we
have a program called meet them at the
gate and it started with anybody that's
coming home we go to the institutions no
matter how far well New Jersey is a
pretty densely populated state so we can
get to all right now I think we have
nine we can get to all nine but Edna
Mayhem is the hardest
but then I quickly learned that I was
ill-equipped to handle the needs of
women coming home from incarceration
I don't know what to buy a woman I don't
know what a five six is or a zero or
nothing like that I don't know how to do
those things so what I did was I
I began to collaborate with Cass severe
who came home who also served time at
the Mayhem and then she took meet him at
the gate and turned it in to meet her at
the gate
and addressed and was duplicating what
we were doing on the male side for the
female side and one thing we all have to
understand in this country women are the
most underserved population in the
cultural state of America
there's no services for them
and that's what your experiencing and
the thing is that got this is what this
is about
how do we begin to imagine spaces or
opportunities or tactics and strategies
to bring forth
those Solutions or methodologies
yeah hi uh thank you so much
um
I've just been thinking about this uh
kind of all day today and Zelda you
mentioned reading the mission statement
through an abolitionist lens kind of
hoping for or imagining a post-cultural
state being led by those that are
currently incarcerated today
and uh I'm curious
for most of you that are working at
these larger institutions that are still
culpable for increased policing in black
and brown neighborhoods in under the
guise of protecting mostly white
students
how do we contend with
those two truths or multiple truths
while leading these great programs and
just existing in those multiple
realities
great question thanks
um
you know
it's uh that's obviously a big problem
at Yale at Columbia and many of these uh
institutions
um
the way I've uh
tried to think about it is
that at these institutions there are
some people who are doing extraordinary
things
and some great centers centers for
justice and others elsewhere
and that
and that there are also these uh other
spaces that are causing harm
and
you have to in in a way I I kind of feel
as if I don't want to give up
claiming
the space for the good
projects
by seeding the ground
to the uh to the nifast in a way
um
and so I mean I
I try as much as possible to
promote and Foster and and uh
support
those spaces that are doing good uh and
also fighting against the other you know
tentacles of these uh
abominable institutions
I think Judith Resnick had her hand up
in the back there
huh
thanks I just wanted to engage a little
bit more with the gender question
um because obviously the institutions
are constructed by and construct a
gender
women are about 10 of the incarcerated
population in the stuff we do on
solitary black women are way over
constrained in solitary than white women
even though solitaries used Less in
women's facilities in facilities
designated for women than facilities
designated for men but
um I'm thinking in in terms of Rachel
and some of the other comments about
in the late 70s the U.S
house held hearings women the Forgotten
offender
aproposa left out not much on the screen
the at the time the federal facilities
had no things called camps which are the
least secure facilities for women at all
but after a lot of activism then there
became a camp actually at Danbury and
then a women's facility for about 1100
people until the Federal Bureau of
Prisons in about 2012-13 decided to move
proposed to move a thousand women to
Aliceville Alabama which is a bad place
to be if you're from Alabama let alone
elsewhere because it's extremely remote
near the Mississippi border so the women
actually who remain a lot of fight and a
small facility for women and lands and
in the wake of covet the and about a
hundred people got out on home
confinement there's a group called the
Danbury 100 organized by these amazing
women who have pulled together and can
connected people who are on home
confinement and are a big fight about
being reincarcerated there so I was
wondering about whether the activism
engagement for women is differently
engaged expressed and or seen even when
it exists and or suppressed and also
what the sort of Library resource is are
including the inside out stuff as well
as
the ways Kathy Boudin and other people's
activism at Bedford has was instrumental
in transforming the facility after an
enormous amount of fighting but she also
had a huge amount of access to resources
to make visible her conflicts around it
so one of the projects for the narrative
imagination would be to try to probe
Rachel's how and where and when is the
our women's facilities under scene
underserved under engaged re-engaged or
differently engaged and how might one
make more accessible the work from the
the work that's going on inside outside
as well as outside work going inside
one one of the biggest hurdles
is when women come home
and they enter into relationships right
and most of their Partners forced them
back into silence
right they don't want anybody to know
that they're they're they're significant
of their loved one partner wife fiance
has been incarcerated
so you go from an environment that does
that to coming home and being in a
relationship that also continues that
same process so when we're at when we're
out in front of Edna Mahan and we're
advocating we're calling for services
we're calling for not reform but
transformation of a system that isolates
and abuses with impunity
it was hard to organize amongst the
women
and when the ones that did come out that
was the first time like it was like a
history in New Jersey to be able to do
that and I understand like that stigma
is harder on I had to learn that it was
harder on women than it was on men
why because they're the mothers
they're the daughters right that gender
specific which you ask is a lot of
things that become what we call a new
entry pop-up barriers
right to being able to tell that story
to be able to go before
um a senate hearing or Capitol Hill
wherever you have to go right it's
almost like they're sworn into secrecy
and silence even after the custodial
term has been served and that's
something that we have to imagine what
can we do to bring them out and to bring
them in safe spaces where they can tell
their stories if anonymously or
specifically without any other harm be
occurring to them and that's the Dilemma
that we face
very interesting I'll take one more
question in the back there you've been
very patient waiting
thank you
uh I just wanted to expand on the
question of the previous person uh my
name is adamu and uh I served over 15
years in California state prisons
um and my question is
around how y'all as
Educators that go inside of Prisons or
run programs that go inside of Prisons
balance I heard one person talk about
using an abolitionist lens or
abolitionist Mission
how do you balance
um the tension between that and the fact
that
educational programs are can be
considered a reform
and so
um
yeah just that reforms in fact
strengthen the system that you know the
history of Prisons is a history of
reforms
um just a quick story I went to I went
and visited Norway this this summer and
toured their prison system and what I
saw there was
um a lot of the same things I mean
Norway has
um
um in some ways done prisons in a way
that's more palatable for their society
and for the world and what I saw was
like a lot of different countries
sending contingents there to tour their
system
um to bring it back to their countries
so that they could like quell Rebellion
um and so
I just think about
you know for myself like education
inside was was a place just like one of
y'all talked about where it felt
non-carcerable it felt like we could
share ideas and there wasn't the threat
of you know prison guards and and and
there was some level of equity between
students
um
but that also the prison uses that as a
way to strengthen itself and to show
like what we're doing and what you know
like these are the advancements that
we're making and like our if if we have
an abolitionist Vision like our ultimate
goal is not to have better universities
inside of Prisons but to like not have
prisons at all right
um
and then like just sorry this maybe
that's good enough but I was just gonna
say that also like Yale
um is not just an institution that has
like a police force but also Yale is an
institution that functions in a lot of
ways like the prison it excludes certain
people and includes certain people just
in the same way that that prison's doing
so like that's also a tension that I
that that exists too right
um yeah so I mean like this the short
answer is yes all of that is absolutely
right
but to the answer the first question you
know I think the way that I wouldn't I
would answer right how do you is it a
reformist reform or is it a
non-reformist reform
I simply believe that what we're doing
is a non-reformist reform in the
shortest way I have of explaining that
is that it helps people get out of
prison you know uh like you heard this
story you you heard Anton's story we
have students who were sentenced to life
in prison you know and who were able to
go through uh you know up to a parole
board or get a sentence modification or
a commutation and for whom you know
having a Yale transcript or showing that
they could enroll right away at UNH was
not a small thing you know and truly led
to people being freed from prison and to
me investing them with that sort of
free freedom but also you know power to
then be in the world and making you know
the advancements towards abolition
toward you know towards you know and I
really appreciate it actually
um what Bernard said about
you know this um it's a battle right
Yale isn't one thing you know we all
carry this label with us and then you
have this responsibility of acting with
it attached to you you know it is a
stigma right just you compared Yale to
the prison it is also a stigma just like
the prison and when we first started
you know researching for this program I
would go to Every you know there's a
women's resettlement working group and a
re-entry Round Table in New Haven and
I'd go to Every you know one of these
meetings with
um my friend James who was an Alum of
the Wesleyan program and they would they
would yeah people people from the
community would yell at us Yale you you
did this to me you did this to me you
did this to me and in a way like yes we
had to sit there and say like yes I have
benefited from this institution that has
done a lot of has done every single
thing you said you know and yet we're
trying to build out something that can
be a part of this you know if you're
imagining a battle of Good and Evil but
at least you know you're staking more
and more people for for this side of a
cause that is moving towards you know
ideally not building a perfect
university in a prison but building you
know building away from having the
prison move moving people outside of
their investing you know power and
Leadership potential into those you know
students who were you know identifying
and investing all of our energy and
money and everything else into
really quickly I mean I think all of
these things are double-edged swords and
they're complicated
conversion stories are double-edged
swords as well right because not
everyone because because for all the
people who've gone through conversion
stories as Caleb was telling us I mean
or the limits of conversion stories is
all of those who've been so damaged by
the prison that there isn't a conversion
story and education also all those who
and it becomes something it becomes the
the test or the way or you know a way to
get out of prison but it's also but it
also fails for so many others so these
are really these are really double-edged
swords and complicated questions and I'm
someone actually who doesn't believe in
non-reformist reform I think
non-reformist reform is just an oxymoron
it's just an easy way out of a
complicated situation as an abolitionist
but I would say that as a personal
ethical Mo as my own ethical
responsibility I cannot simply give up
on
on friends and people who are
in prison
and even if it's going to be and even
and so there's a point at which there's
just an ethical responsibility to care
for others
and one way we can do it is through
Reading
and sharing and talking and thinking
and so I I don't view it as a
non-performance reform I don't think it
you know I don't view Revolution as you
know when you got to come to the
situation where it's really so bad that
people are going to revolt
I think you do
abolitionist work and you also care
and that means going in and
and
sharing
abolition I think that's a good note on
which uh to end and I refers back to
Anton's notion of Liberation education
as as an imaginative ideal but I also
think of the fact that of the class of
25 the
Anton was a member of so far as I know
23 of them still are in
East Jersey and so Liberation is a great
ideal and it also has its limitations
um listen we we reconvene uh in 15
minutes at four o'clock for our readings
by Randall Horton and Richard Rivera and
after that when they're done uh there'll
be a reception upstairs in room 131 uh
to which you are all warmly invited
thank you
[Music]